Selena Gomez arrested and stripping down  in her new music video only ad has this  video of Selena shooting her new music  video in West Hollywood on Sunday night  yep the 23 year olds handcuffed and  thrown into the back of a cop car a  source tells ET that at one point Selena  had to fix her white button-down and  quote unbuttoned it in front of everyone  showing off her black bra seen here the  source adds that the singer seemed to be  in quote good spirits and was laughing  and chatting with the crew very friendly  to everyone  Selena only shot her scene for about  five minutes and spent her downtime in  her dressing room it's unclear which  song the new video is for but on Monday  something too revealed she filmed a  sing-along with the Victoria's Secret  Angels to her tune hands to myself could  that be a hint that the catchy song will  be her new single possibly let us know  what you think on Twitter and use our  hashtag ET now